انسحاب روسيا من خيرسون اعد عقارب الساعه
الى الوراء المشهد يبدو ظاهريا مثلما كان
قبل 9 اشهر اي الايام التي سبقت انطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا لكن
الخفايا لم تتكشف بعد كيف بدات تسترجع
الاراضي التي كانت تحت سيطره الروس باسلوب
يطبعه الحذر
خبراء عسكريون اعتبروا ان قرر الانسحاب لم
يكن مفاجئا بالنظر الى عمليات الاجلاء
الروسيه لسكان المنطقه منذ اسابيع ويعكس
تراجعا عسكريا روسيا امام التوغل
الاوكراني الدفاع البريطانيه قالت من
جهتها ان قدره روسيا على الاحتفاظ بقواتها
على الضفه الغربيه لنهر دين برو في خرسون
واجه الضغوطن بسبب الضربه الاوكرانيه على
طرق اعاده الامداد
اخروني اعتبروا ان الانسحاب قد يشكل
تكتيكا الروسيا لاستدراج القوه الاوكرانيه
ونصب الفخاخ لها قبل الانقضاض عليها
في المقابل ذهب التحليلات لاعتبار ما يحدث
مقدمه للعوده لطاوله المفاوضات خاصه ان
الحربه تشرف على نهايه شهرها التاسع وسط
مؤشره قويه تفيد باستحاله حسم الازمه
عسكريا الانسحاب الروسي طرح اسئله ايضا
بخصوص التعبئه العسكريه التي عرفتها روسيا
للقتال في اوكرانيا مهما يكون من امر فان
الغموض يلف وضع القوه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
فهيتحولت من الهجوم الى الانسحاب التدريجي
مقابل صمود وتقدم للقوه الاوكرانيه التي
تحارب باسلحه الغرب بلال الوجدان العربيه